sí
[Aplausos]
hay atracción entre nosotros
hay una atracción que hay que existe
entre las personas que están aquí
enfrente
y yo
pero esa atracción es mucho más pequeña
que la atracción que hay entre las
personas que están sentadas uno junto a
otro
véanse en las caras
y la atracción que hay con las personas
que están sentadas ahí atrás
y yo
es aún menor
existe
pero no la sienten
esta atracción fue descrita primero por
isaac newton entre 1600 1700 y en esta
esta atracción descrita en un libro
fantástico que se llamaba los principios
de la filosofía natural describe la
gravitación la forma en cómo se mueve el
universo utilizando círculos y
triángulos
y es fantástico este libro y en este
libro a partir de este libro
llega a ciertas conclusiones de las
cuales podemos rescatar tal vez dos la
primera es que esta interacción esta
atracción
sucede a distancia
y la segunda es que sucede de manera
instantánea
y esto lo creímos más o menos como 300
años y en eso se basaba la idea general
de nuestra descripción del universo
a principios de 1900 albert eisntein
dice
a postula una nueva forma de ver el
universo y en esta nueva forma de ver el
universo
entre muchas cosas describe que esta
atracción entre masas uno
no es instantánea sino que se mueve como
lo más rápido que conocemos
la luz a la velocidad de la luz y la
otra cosa es que no sucede a distancia
sino que hay un medio entre todo
en el cual se transmite esta atracción
este medio le llamo el espacio-tiempo
y einstein allí empieza a pensar a lo
grande
dejemos por un momento de pensar en
estas pequeñas masas que somos todos
nosotros y pensemos en grandes masas
piensen en algo muy grande
y además de algo muy grande algo muy
lejano
imaginen
dos estrellas casi muertas los
remanentes estelares les llamamos los
agujeros negros y estos dos agujeros
negros están en algún punto en el
universo lejísimos de aquí moviéndose
extraordinariamente rápido y atrayendo
se cada vez más cada vez más cada vez
más cerca hasta que va a llegar un
momento en el que estos dos agujeros
negros se convierten en uno solo
extraordinariamente grande
y resulta que cuando estos dos agujeros
negros colisionan y forman uno más
grande emiten energía
esta energía se llama energía
gravitacional y viaja como ya les dije
por el espacio-tiempo a la velocidad de
la luz millones y millones de años en
miles de millones de kilómetros
resulta que cuando esto pasa chocan
estos dos agujeros negros
dispersan esta energía esta energía
viaja por el universo
y se tarda estos millones de años en
alcanzar prácticamente todo
particularmente puede alcanzar nuestro
planeta la tierra y cuando llega al
planeta lo deforma no de forma una
manera fantástica
ay quisiera hacer una pequeña precisión
las gravitaciones no son las causantes
de los 19 de septiembre no porque de
hecho nosotros ahora sabemos que esta
gran cantidad de energía que deforma
todo
lo deforma
muy poquito que tanto es poquito más o
menos como 10 millones de veces más
pequeñas que un protón
piensen en esto no crean una gran
cantidad de masa dos grandes agujeros
negros llegan a deformar el
espacio-tiempo donde todos vivimos en
vibraciones 10 millones de veces más
pequeñas que un protón
qué tan pequeño es esto bueno vamos a
ver quisiera que todos tuvieran en la
mente el siguiente número 10 al menos 24
metros algo súper pequeño en nuestra
escala 10 a la 1 metros pues estamos
nosotros ahí están los animales están
empiezan eventualmente a ver algunos
insectos quisiera que se fijarán en la
pantalla en la parte inferior derecha de
la pantalla es el número 10 al menos 4
10 al menos 5 queremos llegar a 10 a la
menos 24 metros para eso tenemos que
llegar pasar la barrera de los virus de
las bacterias de la información genética
de algunos cromosomas de algunas
proteínas
e ir más allá pensemos que tenemos que
pensar romper esa barrera atómica ir más
allá cada vez a lo más pequeño los
núcleos de los átomos
y más allá las partículas más
elementales las cosas que llamamos los
quarks
los elementos más pequeños que conocemos
a la naturaleza ahí vamos apenas vamos
en 10 al menos 19 eventualmente cuando
lleguemos a 10 en la menos 24 nos
estaremos fijando que estamos entre los
quarks y los neutrinos
de este tamaño son las vibraciones que
dos grandes remanentes estelares
estelares provocan al tocar y nosotros
los podemos medir
resulta que desde 1960 se empezó a
planear en la colaboración de
científicos que tenían este objetivo
cómo hacer para poder medir estas
pequeñas vibraciones y entonces se les
ocurrió que bueno vamos a usar un láser
esa luz la conocemos todos tienen un
láser en casa y emitimos el láser
inmediatamente lo dividimos lo hacemos
viajar una distancia kilométrica lo
reflejamos esta misma distancia y cuando
lo dividimos lo reflejamos lo volvemos a
combinar
cuando lo combinamos
si pensamos que la luz es una onda lo
hacemos coincidir de tal manera que uno
de los ases tiene una una cresta y el
otro un valle se acuerdan que son los
enseñaron hace muchos años
y cuando los haces coincidir los sumas
el resultado de cero es decir estos
instrumentos que llamamos
interferómetros se hacen coincidir de
tal manera que están asegurados en donde
no hay señal
cuando pasa una onda gravitacional por
estos interferómetros uno de los brazos
es alargado mientras otro es contraído y
luego el proceso opuesto uno de los
brazos es contraído mientras otro es
alargado y al hacer esto con esta
frecuencia con la que se está moviendo
empieza a desfasar esta señal
una de las cosas más interesantes de
esto es que la frecuencia con la que se
desfasa es exactamente la misma
frecuencia con la que estos dos agujeros
negros se fueron acercando hasta
colisionar y formaron lo más masivo
y entonces de alguna manera lo que
estamos haciendo con estos instrumentos
es sentir el choque los agujeros negros
en la tierra tenemos una gran cantidad
de interferómetros ya funcionando hay
dos en eeuu de que tienen el nombre de
la colaboración que está basada en estas
señas que se llama laico en el estado de
washington y en el estado de luisiana
separados más o menos diez mil
kilómetros además en operación está otro
detector de tres kilómetros cada uno de
los brazos de tres kilómetros que está
en el norte de italia y están en proceso
de producción están en proceso de
construcción laico india en el norte de
la india y cargar a otro instrumento que
estará en japón
piensen en esto estos interferómetros
miden por cada brazo 4 km 3 km y logran
distinguir la diferencia en su tamaño en
el orden de 10 millones de veces más
pequeña que un protón
es algo extraordinario
lo interesante de esto es que como les
dije esta radiación gravitacional viaja
a la velocidad de la luz
y al viajar a la velocidad de la luz
llega al mismo tiempo que la información
astronómica que hemos recibido toda la
vida la luz
cuando esto está empezando a suceder
empezamos a describir nuestras primeras
señales reales de radiación
gravitacional en 2015 tuvimos nuestra
primera detección la colaboración largo
y virgo tuvo esta primera detección una
detección extraordinariamente pequeña
que duró más o menos una décima de
segundo
ese fue el primer descubrimiento
un poquito después en 2015 hubo otra
señal un poquito más larga como un
segundo y medio que es la que está en
naranja
y en 2017 se tuvo otra detección otro
par de detección es la que está en rosa
y en amarillo
y hasta ahí todo iba perfecto entre
otras cosas se había descrito que
efectivamente había sistemas se llaman
binarios sistemas de dos agujeros negros
que coexistían rotaban alrededor de un
centro en común
se combinaban y formaban uno más masivo
esa era algo que estaba descrito en
papel pero que no había sido comprobado
y como les digo la historia era
fantástica
y se puso mejor
por qué
en 2017
se detectó la primera señal de una onda
gravitacional de esta radiación
gravitacional proveniente de dos
estrellas de neutrones otro remanente
estelar que principalmente está
compuesto de neutrones y que es mucho
menos masivo que los agujeros negros
pero que tiene una gran diferencia y es
que
las estrellas de neutrones algunas de
ellas emiten luz
entonces chequen esto porque ahora
tenemos un objeto lejano
con una gran cantidad de materia que
emite luz y nos brinda información con
luz y este mismo que este mismo objeto
lejano que emite ondas gravitacionales
que viajan a la misma velocidad
y llegan exactamente al mismo tiempo a
nosotros
son dos naturalezas diferentes de
información del universo
habíamos sido sordos durante toda
nuestra existencia a esta radiación que
vibra habíamos sido bastante perceptivos
en la luz
ahora le llaman el zoológico de
información pretendemos tener una gran
cantidad de información provenientes de
estrellas remanentes estelares como
agujeros negros
tenemos también en el futuro ideas que
podríamos
y aprender de las estrellas de neutrones
esto se llama astronomía multi mensajera
qué esperamos
saber que hay en el interior de un
agujero negro
saber cómo se comporta una estrella de
neutrones sí
uno de los orígenes del universo que
están limitados a que solamente
recibíamos luz probablemente
es tal vez inconcebible lo que nos
depara el futuro lo que es cierto es que
la astronomía multi mensajera ya empezó
y no hay marcha atrás
sí
[Música]
sí sí